[Music]
the police are investigating a
homicide that occurred over the
weekend how are you greetings from cristian
cásseres with his brief
news now in spanish this happened at a
bodega near valley view and tropicana
on sunday afternoon the police said
that an employee realized that a
man was trying to steal his
vehicle, he pointed a gun at him and
ordered him to stop, the man wanted to flee
the car and that's when the employee
shot him in the head, the subject was
taken to the hospital where
later died the employee who shot him
was taken into custody he is being questioned and i
don't think there will be an
organ donation event monday in the name
of the state patrol officer
who was killed last year this event
will be to honor michael
male who  He was run over by a subject
in a police chase in July of
last year. Everything laughs. It will be held
inside the CNE Barajagua Pérez Sauber building.
ommand and the day of
love and friendship arrived and with it many weddings
here in las vegas to help with the
lawsuit because the county put a
temporary civil registry in the airport facilities it
will be until February 22
which is expected to be a  well-
known date also and despite the fact that we are still
in winter with which
we really have a week and with
really pleasant spring temperatures
several days we are expected to have
temperatures in the 70s as we can see
we will be in the sixties by the start
of the week with winds  Now have
the umbrellas nearby because there will be
chances of rain for Tuesday
I am Cristian Cásseres
informative consultant of they invented Spanish good
day